okay let's go next to our caller from
the four one seven area code who's
calling today from four one seven hi
David this is Jared
hey Jared what's going on yeah hi so I
have a couple of questions um first of
all last night we actually saw a little
bit more of this but um I've noticed
that Bernie has not been talking so much
about campaign finance right which he
was like huge on in 2016 and I think
they're like sorry I'm nervous I think
that uh I think that like that's really
important um and it's and it's like you
know even if we elect Bernie or
Elizabeth Warren it will be important to
solve like the fundamental problem going
forward or we'll just elect people who
talk like progressives but you know
don't actually believe the things they
say yeah yeah that's on that listen
here's what I think is going on there
was a different Bernie this week than in
the first debate and I think people have
been advising him and one of the things
that Bernie is doing is he is number one
being more aggressive which I think
worked well for him and number two I
think he's focusing on what are voting
issues in the Democratic primary the
views of the Democrats that have a shot
in the primary on campaign finance are
relatively similar I'm not saying that
they are the same so I don't think it's
something on which Bernie can
distinguish himself in a way that will
garner him an advantage so I think that
it's I agree that he's not talking about
it as much I think it's strategy and it
may be the right strategy okay
yeah and my other question was actually
about he did a segment on like where you
took a call where someone was talking
about raising the minimum wage and then
like you brought in you bi and you're
saying that both of those things are
band-aids for the more fundamental
problem of you know this vast income
inequality yes the if you so
my mind ubi was sort of like the thing
that wasn't a band-aid um so what if you
do if you think you bi is like you know
just like a band-aid just like raising
wages is what do you think is the
fundamental solution if you concur it's
one it's it's a much bigger
reorganization of the relationship
between corporations government and
elites and basically everybody else
which exceeds sort of the scope of this
call but we may do a deeper dive on it
sometime soon but that's like a major
major topic of that we should dig into
in significant detail and to be clear
ubi
is one type of band-aid just call
something just a band-aid doesn't mean
don't do it but it's just pointing out
that it's not fixing the underlying
issue right okay yeah cool I I would
really love to see like segments or you
know shows in the future where you talk
more about what you think the a more
permanent solution
yes um you know what that would entail
because I'd be curious to hear what your
thoughts are on that all right we will
do that Jared thank you so much for the
call great to hear from you we will take
a quick break if you are holding please
don't hang up because we will get right
back to the phone's momentarily